[Music]
all right hi my name is Jeremy Walker
I'm a developer platform engineer here
at Google and I wanted to talk to you a
little bit about how I use Kotlin to
make white fish watch face creation much
easier on wear watch wear OS so watch
faces are kind of hard right now and you
have to write about 600 plus lines of
code it's not like a nice app you do an
android or iOS where you can declare a
lot of the UI in an XML for XML format
you actually have to manually paint
everything and then you have to include
a bunch of code just to make sure when
you're in ambient mode you're not
hurting the battery life so I was trying
to think of ways to improve this and
last year at i/o we announced official
support for Kotlin so I started thinking
how could I use Kotlin to make this
easier and I did convert the whole thing
to Kotlin which did reduce the code
lines a lot but I found something else
with Colin that made it even more cool
and that was something called DSL so
what does Kotlin DSL
the best way to understand what
domain-specific language is is to
compare it to a regular programming
language so again domain-specific
language that for me didn't really help
me what it meant but if you compare it
to like a general programming language
like Kotlin or java where you have a
bunch of keywords you have classes
methods and you make a nice big app the
ops on the other side is a DSL which
focuses on a specific task or domain so
it four goes a lot of functionality and
lets you just do that specific task
you've actually probably used external
DSL and not even realized it for example
sequel for manipulating databases
that's a DSL so regular expressions for
manipulating strings so they have each
have an independent syntax they reduce a
lot of the functionality you don't need
like methods or or a class to make them
work you're not gonna write a full-on
application in them either at least I
hope not and in for sequel the first key
word kind of indicates as a verb what
you're gonna do maybe you're going to
select or you're gonna update the
disadvantage here is you probably know
is you have to put that as
literal so you have to pray and hope
that you spelled everything right until
run time and then maybe it fails and you
have to pack through it and figure out
what's going on so with Colin DSL it
actually extracts that out of the string
and it puts it right in your codes you
can have type checking you can have code
hints and all that good stuff that comes
with your IDE so now that you kind of in
have an idea of what it is I like to
show you two structures really quick and
I use the ladder but there's one called
creating one through chain method calls
and the other one is nesting of lambdas
so recognizing DSL is really subjective
so you know when you see it so let's see
some so this is Kotlin DSL for sequel
you could probably look at it and if you
know it's sequel you can understand it
right away
and it's all verbs like slice and then I
select all and then I group by they're
not order by and then I limit and this
is all type checked and you get code
hinting so you don't spell anything
wrong and this is pretty great and it's
understandable this is Gaea so but the
DSL for the watch face which I really
liked was the nested lambda structure so
this is to create a watch face you can
see right away create a watch face as a
verb but if you look at my structure you
don't know anything you may not know
anything about making a watch face but
you could probably understand what's
going on right away analog watch face
okay it's not digital so it has arms
colors okay I can figure that out the
dimensions for the hand the hour hand
the minute hand the second hand okay I
understand that watch face background
image so that's all it's very
declarative so you can kind of
understand right away and this is all
type checked and I did code hints and
all that good stuff and in the end I get
this nice little watch face with no work
now the 600 lines didn't all go away I
put them in a helper class and combined
it with the more important class it
interprets this DSL but if you're making
a watch face you only need to know about
the DSL so what's next
I had this was kind of experiment I did
as a code lab so check out the code lab
it'll only take you 15 minutes to make a
new watch face it's a search for Kotlin
watch face code lab jeez that's really
long just search for Google Cloud lab
and it's under the where OS or search
under Kotlin you can see how to make a
watch face and you can see the code or
the source code for how
made the transition between DSL and
interpreted it into a nice little watch
face but more importantly hopefully now
you're a little bit interested in DSL
and say hey I could use this in one of
my projects to make it a little bit
better or you can go out and use
something like the DSL for sequel
there's one for testing and one that's
more similar to mine you can even do
HTML in your collin coding type checked
which is kind of what I modeled wine
after so thank you for the talk letting
me talk and hopefully I've kind of got
you a little bit interested in DSL thank
you
[Applause]
[Music]